give it a house the gate but happy -
hip-hip have it hippity-hoppity go sleep
as my name well let's play some games
like yeah I my balls XL play game all
right so I'm juggling my balls and I
swipe to kick myself Wow
and then I fart to go up and then I hit
my boss and I say ah my boss this has to
be my new favorite game I really like it
we gotta get momentum on that [ __ ] Wow
funny cuz he hits his boss okay if I
tilted I can go further
come on your balls man whoa oh that was
fun for five seconds let's move on to
the next game Pizza vs. skeleton now
this is a quality title have to jump all
right okay oh I'm a pizza whoa oh my god
I'm tilting it [ __ ] you skeletons I'm a
pizza that's a sentence I never thought
I'd say
friends pizza black Oh
Jimmy's making me really hungry all
right that was fun for about five
seconds let's move on to the game that
I've been waiting for all my life mr.
Crabb
mr. Crabb has a game boy my name is mr.
kramm okay you were the cutest
[ __ ] I've seen in my life mr.
crack oh my god this is adorable
mr. crack you're so cute
oh man mr. Crabb what are you doing
you're going backwards mr. Crabb is my
best friend mr. pham is my best friend
mr. Crabb is my best friend mr. Crabb is
mr. Crabb
it's mr. Crabb [ __ ] on it's mr. Krabs
who's that walking there it's mr. Krabs
who's walking over there it's mr. Crabb
miss the crab [ __ ] mr. Krabs
mr. gray don't judge walking of the day
walking over they walking over they it's
mr. Crabb this is [ __ ] awesome are
those your [ __ ] mr. Crabb don't ask
questions [ __ ] I like the game cool
very cool game I would rate a 10 that of
friends skip it's called pancake amazing
ha ha ha ha ha
I'm so glad someone made a game like
this this needed to be made 6 oh my god
8h gag cakes flips man what the [ __ ]
it's really hard it looks easy [ __ ] say
I want to be 8 come on let me [ __ ] you
then let's get 10 ah ah ah thank you
why let's move on to the next game this
is really hard
come on man
I got zero are you kidding me stop
getting zero oh okay I'm starting to
understand the gist of it no [ __ ] you
then let's move on oh [ __ ] this one is
made by catch snap catch app which means
it's gonna be all hard as hell what
I'm a jeweler for Sweden I August hahaha
yes yes ah polar bear so you can't [ __ ]
this yes 1000 feel my jelly [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you felt it 14 hey that's pretty
good
ah 12 ah
oh God 14 come on baby 15 16 17
oh god oh my god oh my god no yes
first get after that episode they're
like if you enjoyed this always thank
you so much for watching click here to
watch more similar videos and I'll see
you Bros in the next one stay awesome
bros go Jesus Go Go juice go Jesus Jesus
Jesus Jesus yes
oh god what is happening how many
parcels fine for fun bit did I fail what
is this game